[Applaudissements]
toutes les vidéos en direct vidéo on
voit toutes les vidéos ou les boîtes
tout gildas petite surprise ça vous dit
j'ai monté un nouveau groupe à quelques
jours de la présidentielle
j'ai décidé de monter un groupe en fait
qui chante avec des noms d'hommes
politiques célèbres et pour monter ce
groupe je me suis associé toute l'équipe
d'alibi qui cartonne trois millions et
demi d'entrées pour le film animé ce
thème fort et on a créé ce groupe là on
vous présente l'album c est quoi en fait
c'est quoi si une pub voilà c'est celle
a pu du prochain album qu'on va sortir
on met des noms de politis dans les
chansons jamais l'âge de ces partis la
politique et la variété
alors vont s'acheter l'album et
politiques lovers
le premier point qui intègre les hommes
politiques dans des tubes préférés
[Musique]
choisis ton jeu
rencontre
les amarres
pompidou
[Musique]
betty covers a pas besoin d'attendre le
1er tour vous acheter leurs 45 tours
[Musique]
mais
o'meara tout séjour tout ce temps où tu
n'as pas de week-end
un disque acheté un poste d'assistant
parlementaire offert jah
[Musique]
le jour et je remets le jour
[Applaudissements]
mes amis mes cartons d'animaux merci